- My name is Sebastian Gonzalez
and I'm gonna be surprising
my mom with a tattoo.
- Honestly, we could get any
number of reactions from my family.
- Something about
tattoos just speak to me.
It's dope, but they
wouldn't let me get one so.
- None of my family has
ever gotten a tattoo.
- I don't think my mom
is gonna be too happy.
- I ended up choosing a
Koi fish, just because
it fits in with the whole
zen vibe of my family.
- I'll be getting a dragon tattoo.
My mom's pretty smart but
also I really dig dragons.
- A little bit nervous
but at the same time,
I think this is gonna be great.
- He was such a good kid.
He just was always very, just listen.
(laughs)
- Very proud of you. You know, I just.
- Thanks ma. I'd never wanna do anything
that would take away from that
pride that you have in me.
- Well I want to give him his space,
but I would hope that
he was honest with me.
- Yeah.
- Do you remember when I was
like talking to the two of you
about Tom's birthday, like
the weekend before last?
- Yes.
- And I got a little bit
heavily under the influence.
Well, there's like one other thing I
ended up doing that night.
- (sighs)
The real reason why I brought you here
wasn't for really any of this.
- What?
- Just.
- You're (bleep) me. Sebastian.
When did you get that?
- I got it like a couple of weeks ago.
- You're dad is gonna kill you, dude.
- No ma, no.
- Alright so.
- Oh my gosh! It's beautiful.
- I got a Koi fish.
- Was it painful?
- I don't really remember.
- No, well good.
- I wanted a tattoo and you
said you like personal space.
I do what I want.
- What is it?
- It's like a dragon with
smokes and stuff like that.
- It looks like scribbles to me Sebastian.
- Come on mom now you're just being mean.
- Oh my God.
- I love the Koi fish.
It's kind of tied in
with Papa Ross, my dad.
He had a beautiful Koi pond.
And who actually had a heart attack
right next to his Koi pond.
And it was the most
peaceful way for him to go.
It was a blessing.
- Do you even know, like
when you got the tattoo,
like what does it mean to you?
- It means strength, resilience,
and that I really like
Lord of the Rings so yeah.
- I don't know why I thought, you know,
that you had gotten in
trouble with the law
or you decided to go sleep with a hooker.
And I was like oh no.
So a tattoo is mild.
- Oh ok.
- I've gone through this with him before.
I got a tattoo when I was 18,
but now I'm 44 years old.
I wanna get it off.
I'm disappointed. At
least talk to me about it.
- (sighs)
- And especially that color.
- (laughs) wow mom.
- I've considered tattoos myself.
- What would you get for a tattoo?
- Maybe an octopus.
Thank God it wasn't a prostitute.
- Oh more? Like what else can you tell me?
- (sighs)
- Oh great.
- Calm down.
Alright, the tattoo's fake mom.
- (laughs) Let me see.
- The tattoo's fake mom,
like you can scrape it off just barely.
- (laughs) Thank God you didn't get it.
- I just want to give you
one last look of the tattoo.
- Yes.
- Cause it's actually gonna wash off.
(laughs) It's not a real tattoo.
- Really?
- You don't understand how
much it was gonna cost us
to get that lasered off.
- Who said I was gonna get it lasered off?
- I'm shaking I'm so happy!
(laughs)
- It's a beautiful tattoo though.
- You didn't want to go for something
a little more masculine?
- (laughs)
- I want to give you
your personal space, but
like something like that is big.
Tagging yourself and doing
that is not what makes you.
You is what makes you.
- Don't get an octopus tattoo.
Cause I think the octopus
would be a little.
- Scary?
- Scary.